a show of force in corsica's capital at
jackson
the target of their anger government
buildings a courthouse a bank and the
police here responding with tear
gas violence started after jailed
corsican nationalist yvonne kolona was
beaten into a coma by a fellow inmate
you have to be violent to be heard it's
not normal when you're afraid of the
confrontations then the state gives in
it's unfortunate that it has come to
this you have to wait until a man is in
a coma to react
once france's most wanted man yvonne
coloner is serving a life sentence in
southern france for killing an official
in 1998
his demand for transfer to corsica had
been ignored until tuesday
under immense pressure from protesters
prime minister jean-claude stex allowed
the order after the attack
many here blame the french government
for the assault
[Music]
and say the transfer order came too late
what happened is very serious the
assassination attempt on ivan kolona is
very very serious and so i think that
many people on the continent are not
aware of what really happened and of the
expectations of the corsican people
days of protests have spread across the
cities of ajaxio calvi and bastia
the anger is not new to the island where
protests and calls for nationalism have
been a mainstay for decades
but in recent years more people have
opted for autonomy over independence
in one week the young people have
obtained what no one no elected official
has obtained for seven years
the koskinen people are in the street
that's how it is and the actions must
continue
many here say the only way of making
change is on the streets
laura about a manly al jazeera